c'était il ya très très très longtemps
c'était tilly a très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait les alpes à
gauche des alpes
il y avait la planète sa voix elle
n'était pas plate du tout mais toute
cabossée sur la planète savoie il y
avait des savoyards voici un savoyard vu
de près il y avait des savoyards de deux
sortes des savoyards du haut et des
savoyards du bas qui vivaient de l'autre
côté
au fil du temps la planète sa voix riche
et prospère était convoité par ses
voisins qui se disputait son territoire
la savoie rapetisser ou s'agrandissait
au gré des conquêtes
c'était très gênant surtout pour les
savoyards comme la savoie changer de
forme il eu des savoyards qui en eurent
donc assez au bout d'un moment
alors ils décidèrent les uns et les
autres d'aller dans la france qui avait
l'air de mieux marcher si bien qu'un
jour il y eut un référendum qui
officialiser ce changement de frontière
mais les savoyards avait-il peur de ne
plus être savoyard pour rester des
savoyards certains affirment r il suffit
que nous conservions notre patrimoine
c'est pourquoi tous les agents de la
médiathèque de chambéry conservait
conservait concernés il conservait dans
la joie il conservait dans l'allégresse
et quand il ne conservait pas il rêvait
qu'ils conservaient les français de leur
côté laissé faire et venait en vacances
rendre visite aux savoyards ils
s'amusaient comme des fous faisait du
ski et des randonnées pendant ce temps
les savoyards conservait conservait
conserver mais la conservation
n'allait-elle pas figé la planète sa
voix pour toujours
c'est génial
il faut être ça il faut être l'embryon
pour la connaître
en fait c'est le monument le plus connu
à chambéry c'est la fontaine des
éléphants qui s'appelle les 400 culs et
n'ont curieusement c'est l'éléphant est
devenu un peu le symbole de chambéry est
donc là en fait on a fait genre l'ours
jaloux qui cherche aussi des copains
pour faire une fontaine c'est la main je
retiens et les français partiront en
vacances à la montagne
[Musique]